[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour un nouveau
numéro du 7-8 échos votre magazine
d'actualités économiques dans les
yvelines tout de suite le sommaire de
cette édition c'est le rendez vous pour
les industriels de la défense maritime
le salon euronaval s'est tenu du 23 au
26 octobre au bourget et des entreprises
yvelinoise était au rendez-vous nous
sommes allés les rencontrer reportage à
suivre
une soirée pour présenter les services
de saint quentin en yvelines
le principe de la welcome party avec
l'objectif d'attirer les salariés des
entreprises saint-quentinoise travailler
et vivre sur le territoire c'est le
dossier de cette émission avec nos deux
invités anne faille et antoine beau
enfin retrouvez l'actualité économique
en bref avec les derniers chiffres du
chômage dans le département ou encore
l'ouverture d'un tunnel de lavage
automobile à elancourt tout droit venu
des états unis et sur notre plateau de
deux invités anne failli donc vous êtes
directrice générale adjointe au
développement économique à saint quentin
en yvelines et antoine beau vous êtes
directeur de l'habitat et de la
rénovation urbaine à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonsoir à tous
les deux alors avant de nous intéresser
à la question de l'attractivité du
territoire la 26e édition du salon
euronaval du 23 au 26 octobre le monde
industriel de la marine s'est rassemblée
au bourget plusieurs secteurs
représentés comme la défense la sécurité
et la sûreté maritimes 470 exposants
être en trop après 33 pays présents
parmi eux des entreprises yvelinoise
regardez c'est le fournisseur de l'armée
française et il est yvelinois le groupe
nexter basés à satory participent à la
fabrication des engins de l'armée de
terre il fournit aussi les munitions de
la marine nationale pour euronaval il
vient présenter sa nouveauté le rapid
fire une tourelle équipé d'un canon
télescoper de 40 millimètres fabriqué
avec l'entreprise thalès et bea systems
destinés aux navires il ya là un
problème de la piraterie
le problème des drones aujourd'hui ces
bâtiments sont attaqués par les zodiac
et pour répondre à ces menaces et
menaces asymétriques
on a besoin d'avoir des canons de ce
type là qui permette véritablement de
cibler et de protéger les navires de
guerre mais surtout les navires de
logistique de l'armée française en avec
atos aux clayes-sous-bois thales à
elancourt ou encore airbus saint quentin
en yvelines est représenté dans le
domaine naval le géant européen de
l'aéronautique possède notamment des
services d'imagerie satellite conçu en
partie sur le site élan courtois est une
activité autour de l'imagerie satellite
qui permet d'aller dans des zones
éloignées regarder ce qui se passe
détecté de la pollution de détecter
des problèmes de trafic
des transports de drogue
les armes illégales et j'ai été très
très rapidement et on peut très bien à
partir des images satellites à les
observer quelque part une zone à côté
des grands groupes il ya aussi des pme
comme sierra packaging basée à buc avec
deux millions de chiffre d'affaires par
an cette entreprise est spécialisée dans
la découpe de mousse pour le transport
d'armes de radio ou de matériel
électronique de l'armée française
on a mis deux types de mousses une qui
est basse densité pour venir absorber
les vibrations une qui haute densité
pour venir protéger la maquette les
contraintes du client a besoin de les
comprendre pour savoir si c'est lourd 6
a besoin d'avoir une mousse anti
statique 6 a besoin d'avoir une mousse
retardant tofu et en fait on vient
usines et tout sur place on a notre
stock de mousser en usine tout abus qu
euronaval une opportunité pour ces
entreprises de rencontrer de nouveaux
partenaires
l'industrie navale de défense représente
près de 45 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires dans le monde
saint quentin en yvelines a organisé le
9 octobre dernier la ou welcome party un
événement pour présenter les différents
services mis à disposition des salariés
des entreprises et des habitants de
l'agglomération
écoutez à ce sujet le président de saint
quentin en yvelines jean michel fourgous
c'était vraiment améliorée donc la vie
des salariés dans saint quentin en
yvelines pour bien sûr le aussi le
à la demande de nos entreprises ont pour
bien montrer que saint quentin et à une
culture très proche de l'entreprise et
kelly là pour pour participer à la russe
de nos entreprises
alors une faille on vient d'entendre
jean michel fourgous parler de réussite
des entreprises en partie grâce à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines comment vous
participez à cette réussite à la
réussite des entreprises sur saint
quentin en yvelines c'est d'abord de
trouver un environnement qui leur permet
de développer leurs innovations de
développer leur chiffre d'affaires et en
rejoignant paris saclay le coeur
économique de paris saclay elle trouve
là l'ensemble des ingrédients favorable
à l'heure à leur réussite alors réussite
et à leur capacité évidemment de
recrutement de collaborateurs qui est
aujourd'hui un élément essentiel de leur
de leurs performances économiques
alors comment vous vous accompagnez
justement quels services vous proposer
pour les salariés des entreprises
saint-quentinoise les salariés ont ainsi
nombre de services qui sont à leur
disposition d'abord c'est de pouvoir
travailler au sein d'un environnement où
il fait bon vivre où il y à un pôle
commercial actif premier pôle commercial
des yvelines où il y à une offre de
services capacité d'aller rencontrer
telle ou telle profession médicale
pendant la pause méridienne après donc
il trouve là un lieu de vie qui
correspond d'ailleurs aux attentes des
collaborateurs notamment des plus jeunes
des collaborateurs qui cherche dans lieu
de travail aussi un lieu un lieu de vie
un lieu et vont pouvoir rencontrer
d'autres d'autres collaborateurs et
c'est tout ça que nous mettons en place
sur 50 ans alors vous antoine beau je le
rappelle vous êtes directeur de
l'habitat de la rénovation urbaine on
entend le président parlait aussi de
demandes des entreprises
concrètement qu'est ce qu'elle vous
demande vous par rapport à votre domaine
d'activité l'habitat le logement alors
le triptyque développement économique
logement et mobilité ça constitue
justement le développement urbain et
l'agglomération s'est toujours attaché
un sujet principal quel rapprochement
habitat emploi et là plusieurs titres
tout d'abord le rapprochement habitants
emploient ça permet un gain de temps
pour les salariés à moins de stress dont
social ça permet aussi en développement
je dirais développement durable meilleur
est donc aujourd'hui
finalement c'est depuis l'origine de la
vie de nouvel objectif c'était que 50%
des salariés habitent sur le territoire
on essaye de maintenir cet objectif on
en est encore un peu loin à un tiers
l'objectif c'est de se dire bah
finalement peut-être que ont justement
il ya des services sur le territoire et
on peut aussi vivre et se développer et
c est du coup y habiter alors finalement
les habiter c'est un parcours du
combattant
il ya beaucoup d'offres il ya
différentes choses il faut savoir
trouver la bonne solution
donc l'agglomération a mis en place
plusieurs outils
depuis quelques années on a mis en place
un guide du logement des salariés
ça sert à la fois aux salariés et aussi
aux chefs d'entreprises puisque aussi
les chefs d'entreprise de pme ne peuvent
pas s'occuper de toutes les
problématiques là on est là en soutien
auprès des chefs d'entreprises et donc
on met aussi en place des forums
logement or il forum logement c'est
assez simple finalement au var aux
saints au coeur de l'entreprise
on vient avec une batterie de deux
personnes de tout de tout service
parapublic pour orienter faciliter leur
recherche c'est comme un circuit la
personne est une problématique de
logements ont pu leur enseigner avec des
questions juridiques ont une personne à
des questions sur les questions
énergétiques on peut la renseigner
finalement on vient l'aider faciliter sa
recherche
et c'est tout l'enjeu du service public
aussi de faciliter les recherches pour
les salariés alors vous avez mentionné à
un chiffre et ça a été mentionné
plusieurs fois pendant la welcome party
ces deux tiers des salariés donc je
rappelle il ya 145 1000 salariés sur
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines deux tiers seulement non deux
tiers ne vivent pas sur le territoire
comment alors on ne peut pas appeler ça
un problème est comment vous cher
comment vous faites pour attirer
justement et faire venir ses salariés
pour qu'ils puissent vivre sur le
territoire
c'est une situation qu'on retrouve sur
l'ensemble de l'île de france qui n'est
pas qui n'est pas spécifique à saint
quentin en yvelines
mais le fait d'être un pôle d'emploi
majeur évidemment krékré c'est tendance
cédant cela il faut pouvoir montrer aux
salariés que sur le territoire on a une
offre de service qui correspond à leurs
attentes
et cette offre est parfois
insuffisamment connue
gray l'ensemble des outils qui sont mis
en place en train de le rappeler le tout
les livres et sur les logements donc la
façon dont on opère c'est d'aller au
contact direct de ces de ses salariés
notamment dans au moment où ils arrivent
sur le territoire donc on a toutes une
offre de services on a appelé welcome
back au sens le kit de kylie a à leur
arrivée sur sur le territoire où on va
les amener au travers de deux visites
terrain en allant voir la fois les
offres de logement les offres
d'équipements publics l'offre l'offre
sportive qui est un élément très fort de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines donc notre
objectif c'est de faire connaître déjà
cette offre auprès des salariés
notamment de ceux qui rejoignent ce pôle
d'activité quai saint quentin en
yvelines
on arrive bientôt au terme de cet
entretien un dernier mot pour conclure
peut-être sur cette application vivre ou
si une application que vous avez
présenté lors de la welcome party
donc c'est une start up i tract qui
originaire de lyon et avec qui vous
travaillez qu'est ce que c'est vivre où
ça concerne notamment le logement
or vous c'est une bonne idée c'est une
application on est de plus en plus dans
l'ère numérique
effectivement aujourd'hui il existe une
multitude de sites pour retrouver des
situations de deux des projets de
logements et vivre où finalement ça
vient qualifié sa recherche de logement
identifier les bonnes commune les bons
secteurs au regard de différents
critères chacun ses propres critères et
pelé pondérer c'est tout l'intérêt c'est
que on fait sa recherche en pondérant
choisi ma priorité c'est les écoles etc
ça vient faciliter sa recherche un
système de scoring derrière il ya la
grosse machinerie de calcul assez poussé
mes intérêts c'est finalement de
simplifier d'orienter et après de
proposer les offres disponibles sur le
territoire et pour conclure ce sera mis
en place à quel moment a failli nous ne
les voyons aujourd'hui auprès de cinq
entreprises que cinq grands comptes du
territoire on touchera plus de dix mille
salariés
notre objectif c'est de mettre à
disposition notamment des directeurs des
ressources humaines des outils pour
pouvoir expliquer ce qu'est l'offre de
saint quentin en yvelines avec comme tu
disais entraîne une application
numérique correspond aux attentes
aujourd'hui de nos données
arie de nos collaborateurs et puis très
rapidement après cette phase
d'expérimentation un déploiement à
l'échelle de l'ensemble du territoire ce
sont les entreprises qui nous ferons
appel à 7 à cette application et qui
ensuite la proposeront à leurs salariés
une faille et antoine beau merci d'être
venu sur notre plateau et on passe tout
de suite à l'actualité économique en
bref le chômage en hausse dans les
yvelines le nombre de chômeurs inscrits
à pôle emploi toutes catégories
confondues a augmenté de 3,8 pour cent
dans le département façon 200 3770 fin
juin à 107 1780 personnes fin septembre
concernant les demandeurs d'emploi sans
activité en catégorie a ils sont 66330
fin septembre soit une augmentation de 5
3% par rapport au mois de juin une
première en ile-de-france avec ce nouvel
équipement le site gde de limay vient de
se doter d'une unité de traitement des
produits métalliques par décapage un
moyen de recycler des matériaux un
investissement qui a nécessité
l'embauché de quatre personnes c'est un
tunnel de lavage importés directement
des états unis ce centre de lavage
installé à elancourt s'est doté de cet
outil
l'automobiliste reste dans sa voiture et
des employés nettoient la voiture en
plusieurs étapes
d'autres services sont proposés en
illimité comme l'aspirateur le laf tapis
ou le gonfleur tout cela à la mode
américaine
c'est un mode de lavage très efficace
qui permet de laver rapidement sans
attendre pour les clients puisque les
voitures sont insérés minutes après
minutes dans le tunnel de lavage et on
peut avoir plusieurs voitures qui se
lavent en même temps
avant de refermer ce magazine noter dans
vos agendas pour le mois de novembre
si vous avez un projet innovant que vous
souhaitez développer depuis le 18
octobre et jusqu'au 20 novembre vous
pouvez déposer votre candidature pour
rejoindre l'incubateur ski cube
vous pourrez alors bénéficier d'un
accompagnement et de prestations mises
en place par l'agglomération pour plus
d'informations rendez vous sur le site
internet sky entreprise.com troisième
édition du sky business day au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
il a lieu le jeudi 8 novembre grands
groupes pme tpe ou start up plus de 1000
entreprises sont attendues durant cet
événement avec comme objectif de
développer son réseau d'affaires de
découvrir de nouvelles innovations ou de
rencontrer de potentiels partenaires
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de nous
avoir suivis vous pourrez revoir cette
émission en replay sur notre site
internet ou sur l'application mobile tv
78 on se retrouve le mois prochain pour
une édition consacrée aux cayes business
day à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]